after 13.8 billion years of cosmic
history our universe has woken up and
become aware of itself from a small blue
planet tiny conscious parts of our
universe have begun gazing out into the
cosmos with telescopes discovering
something humbly no we've discovered
that our universe is vastly grander that
our ancestors imagined another life
seems to be an almost imperceptibly
small perturbation on an otherwise dead
universe but we've also discovered
something inspiring which is that the
technology we're developing has the
potential to help life flourish like
never before
not just for centuries but for billions
of years and not just on earth but
throughout much of this amazing cosmos I
think of the earliest life is life 1.0
this is really dumb like bacteria unable
to learn anything during its lifetime
I think you must humans is life 2.0
because we can learn which being nerdy
geek speek might think of his installing
new software into our brains like
languages and job skills life 3.0 which
can design not only its software but
also its hardware of course doesn't
exist yet but perhaps our technology has
already made us life to point one with
artificial knees pacemakers and cochlear
implants so let's take a closer look at
our relationship with technology okay as
an example the Apollo 11 moon mission
was both successful and inspiring
showing that when we humans use
technology wisely we can accomplish
things that our ancestors could only
dream of but there's an even more
inspiring journey propelled by something
more powerful than rocket engines where
the passengers aren't just three
astronauts but all of humanity let's
talk about our collective journey into
the future with artificial intelligence
my friend young Talon likes to point out
that just as with rocketry it's not
enough to make our technology powerful
we also have to figure out if we're
gonna be really ambitious
spirit and where we want to go with it
so let's talk about all three artificial
intelligence
look power the steering and the
destination let's start with the power I
define intelligence very inclusively
simply as our ability to accomplish
complex goals because I want to include
both biological and artificial
intelligence and I want to avoid the
silly carbon chauvinism idea that you
can only be smart if you made of meat
it's really amazing how the power of AI
has grown recently just think about it
not long ago robots couldn't walk now
they can do backflips not long ago we
didn't have self-driving cars now we
have self flying rockets not long ago
hey I couldn't do face recognition now
hey I can generate fake faces and
simulate your face saying stuff that you
never said not long ago hey I couldn't
be this at the game of Go then google
deepmind's alpha 0 AI it took three
thousand years of human go games and go
is them ignore it all and became the
world's best player by just playing yes
itself and the most impressive feat here
wasn't that it crushed human gamers but
that it crushed human AI researchers
who'd spent decades handcrafting game
playing software and alpha zero crushed
human AI researchers not just a goal but
even the chess that we've been working
on since 1950 so all this amazing recent
progress in the eye really begs the
question how far will it go I like to
think about this question in terms of
this abstract landscape of tasks where
the elevation represents how hard it is
for a height of Billy's task in human
level and the sea level represents what
AI can do today the sea level is rising
is a I improved so there's a kind of
global warming going on here in the task
landscape and the obvious takeaway is to
avoid careers at the waterfront
but you'll soon be automated and
disruptive but there's a much bigger
question as well how high will the water
enterprising will it eventually rise the
flood everything matching human
intelligence at all tasks this is the
definition of artificial general
intelligence AGI which has been the holy
grail of AI research since its inception
but this definition people will say well
there'll always be jobs that humans can
do better than machines are simply
saying that we'll never get AGI sure we
might still choose to have some human
jobs or to give humans in common purpose
without jobs but AGI would in any case
transform life as we know it with humans
no longer being the most intelligent now
if the water level does reach AGI right
then further AI progress will be done
mainly not by humans but by AI which
means that there's a possibility that
further AI progress could be way faster
than the typical human research and
development timescale of years raising
the controversial possibility of an
intelligence explosion where recursively
self-improving AI rapidly leaves human
intelligence far behind creating what's
known as super intelligence alright
reality check are we gonna get AGI
anytime soon
some famous AI researchers like Rodney
Brooks think it won't happen for
hundreds of years but others like google
deepmind founder demis hassabis are more
optimistic and i'm working to try to
make it happen much sooner and recent
surveys have shown that most a AI
researchers actually shared them as as
optimism expecting that we will get AGI
within decades so within the lifetime of
many ellis which begs the question and
then what what do we want the role of
humans to be if machines can do
everything better and cheaper than us
the way I see it we face a choice one
option is to be complacent we can say ah
let's just build machines but can do
everything we can do and not worry about
the consequences come on if we build
technology that makes all you mazhab
leave what could possibly go wrong but I
think that would be embarrassing Lee
Lane I think we should be more ambitious
in the spirit of Ted let's envision the
truly inspiring high-tech future and try
to steer towards it this brings us to
the second part of a rocket metaphor the
steering we're making AI more powerful
but how can we steer towards the future
where AI help humanity flourish rather
than flounder to help with this I
co-founded the future life Institute's
the small nonprofit promoting beneficial
technology used in our goal is simply
for the future of life to exist and
these inspiring is possible you know I
love technology technology is why today
is better than the Stone Age and I'm
optimistic that we can create a really
inspiring high-tech future if and this
is a big if if we win the wisdom race
the race between the growing power of
our technology and the growing wisdom
with which we manage it but this is
going to require a change of strategy
because our own strategy has been
learning from mistakes we invented fire
screwed up a bunch of times invented the
fire extinguisher we invented the car
traffic light the seatbelt and the
airbag but with more powerful technology
like nuclear weapons and a GI learning
from mistakes is a lousy strategy don't
you think it's much better to be
proactive rather than reactive plan
ahead and get things right the first
time because that might be the only time
we'll get but it is funny because
sometimes people tell me max Shh don't
talk like that
that's not a scare mongering but it's
not scare mongering it's what we in MIT
call safety engineering think about it
before NASA launched the Apollo 11
mission they systematically thought
through everything that could go wrong
when you put people on top of explosive
fuel types and launch them somewhere
where no one could help them and there
was a lot that could go wrong was that
scare mongering no that was precisely
the safety engineering and then ensure
the success of a mission and that is
precisely mr.
I think we should take with Ag I think
through what can go wrong to make sure
it goes right so in this spirit
we've organized conferences bringing
together leading AI research another
thing here's that discuss how to grow
this wisdom we need to keep AI
beneficial our last conference was in
Asilomar California last year and
produced this list of 23 principles
which have since been signed by over a
thousand AI researchers and key industry
leaders and I want to tell you about
three of these principles one is that we
should avoid an arms race and lethal
autonomous weapons the idea here is that
any science can be used for new ways of
helping people or any ways of harming
people
for example biology and chemistry are
much more likely to be used for new
medicines or new cures than for new ways
of killing people because biologists and
chemists pushed hard and successfully
for bans on biological and chemical
weapons and in the same spirit most AI
researchers want to stigmatize and ban
lethal autonomous weapons another
Asilomar AI principle is that we should
mitigate AI fuel income inequality I
think that if we can grow the economic
pie dramatically with AI and we still
can't figure out how to divide this pie
so everyone gets better off then shame
on us
all right now raise your hand if your
computer has ever crashed wow that's a
lot of hands well then you'll appreciate
this principle look then we should
invest much more in AI safety research
because as we put AI in charge of ever
more decisions and infrastructure we
need to figure out how to transform
today's buggy and hackable computers
into robust AI systems that we can
really trust otherwise all this awesome
new technology can malfunction and harm
us or get hacked and be turned against
us and this AI safety work has to
include work on AI value alignment
because the real threat from AGI isn't
malice like in silly Hollywood movies
but competence AGI accomplishing goals
just aren't aligned with ours for
example when we humans drove the West
African black rhino extinct we didn't do
it because we were a bunch of evil
rhinoceros haters did we we did it
because we were smarter than them and
our goals weren't aligned with theirs
but AGI is by definition smarter than us
so to make sure that we don't put
ourselves in the position of those
rhinos if we create AGI we need to
figure out how to make machines
understand our goals adopt our goals and
retain our goals and whose goal should
these be anyway which goals should they
be this brings us to the third part of
our rocket metaphor the destination
we're making AI more powerful trying to
figure out how to steer it but where do
we want to go with it this is the
elephant in the room that almost nobody
talks about not even here at Ted because
we're so fixated on short term AI
challenges look our species is trying to
build a GI motivated by curiosity and
economics but what sort of future
society are we hoping for if we succeed
we did an opinion poll on this recently
and I was struck to see that most people
actually want us to build super
intelligence AI that's vastly smarter
than us in all ways what there was the
greatest agreement on was that we should
be ambitious and help life spread into
the cosmos but there was much less
agreement about who or what should be in
and I was a secret the muse to see that
some people who wanted to be just
machines and there was told this
agreement about what the role of humans
should be even at the most basic level
so let's take a closer look at possible
futures that we might choose to steer
toward alright so don't get me wrong
here I'm not talking about space travel
merely about humanity's metaphorical
journey into the future so one option
that some of my colleagues like is to
build super intelligence and keep it
under human control like an enslaved God
disconnected from the internet and used
to create unimaginable technology and
wealth forever controls it but you know
Lord Acton warned us that power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
so you might worry that maybe we humans
just aren't smart enough or wise enough
rather behind this much power
also aside from any moral qualms you
might have about enslaving superior
Minds you might worry that maybe the
super intelligence could outsmart us
break out and take over but I also have
colleagues who find with AI taking over
and even causing human extinction as
long as we feel that the AIS are are
worthy descendants like our children but
how would we know that a eyes have
adopted our best values and aren't just
unconscious zombies tricking us into
anthropomorphizing them and also
shouldn't those people who don't want
human extinction haven't stay in the
matter - now if you didn't like either
of those two high tech options it's
important to remember that low tech is
suicide from a cosmic perspective
because if we don't go far beyond
today's technology the question isn't
whether Humanity is going to go extinct
merely
whether we're gonna get taken out by the
next killer asteroid supervolcano or
some other problem a better technology
could have solved so how about having
your cake and eating it with a GI that's
not enslaved but treats us well because
its values are aligned with ours this is
a gist of what eliezer yudkowsky has
called friendly AI and if we can do this
it could be awesome it could not only
eliminate negative experiences like this
these poverty crime and other suffering
but could also give us the freedom to
choose between some fantastic new
diversity of positive experiences
basically making us the masters of our
own destiny so in summary our situation
with technology is complicated but the
big picture is rather simple most AI
researchers expect AGI within decades
and if we just bumble into this
unprepared it will probably be the
biggest mistake in human history let's
face it it could enable brutal global
dictatorship but unprecedented
inequality surveillance suffering and
maybe even human extinction but if we
steer carefully we could end up in a
fantastic future where everybody is
better off the poor are richer the
richer richer everybody is healthy and
free to live out their dreams now hang
on do you folks want the future that's
politically right or left do you want
the pious society with strict moral
rules or do you want a hedonistic we for
all more like Burning Man 24/7 do you
want beautiful beaches forests lakes or
would you prefer to rearrange some of
those atoms the computer is enabling
virtual experiences with friendly AI we
could simply build all of these
societies and give people the freedom to
choose which one they want to live in
because we would no longer be limited by
our intelligence merely by the laws of
physics so the resources and spaceless
would be astronomical literally so
here's our choice we can either be
complacent about our future take me as
an article of blind faith that any new
technology is guaranteed to be
beneficial and just repeat that to
ourselves the mantra over and over and
over again as we drift like a rudderless
ship towards our own obsolescence or we
can be ambitious thinking hard about how
to steer our technology and where we
want to go with it to create the age of
amazement we're all here to celebrate
the age of amazement and I feel that its
essence should lie on becoming not
overpowered but empowered by our
technology thank you
[Applause]
[Music]